good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is a beautiful
Wednesday here in New York City hey
Claude hyd
hey Jax I'm feeling good happy hump day
to everyone make sure to hump someone
you love whether that's your partner
your significant other or just your dog
I already humped Thea this morning so
I'm Way ahead of schedule oh wow
speaking of home today where is co oh
he's far he usually likes to watch the
action but he's just not interested in
the show anymore well if you want your
heart to die last night we were watching
Handmaid's Tale which I have to talk
about I watched some of the most [ __ ]
up episodes I couldn't like it was just
awful um and he hopped off the bed like
he was dead asleep but it was so weird
and he jumped into the love sack and
like spent the majority of the night
there I mean he just loves the sack he
puts the love in love sack so true wow
that is so cute also just on the subject
of Theo not really a great segue we
recorded the patreon episode yesterday
me and Claudia and it might go down as
our strangest yet funniest episode of
all time I'm gonna post it later today
but it was we could not stop laughing
and I don't know if it was because it
was the first time we recorded an
episode together in person in person
this time and we were just like feeding
off of each other's energy but oh my god
we were legit like peeing sweating
crying and it's so funny so head over to
patreon.com/scishow morning tous it'll
be up like right after this episode most
of the episode is just both of us like
wheezing into the microphone so I
actually think people will enjoy it it
was so random the theme of the episode
was we tried to follow in the footsteps
of our you know fellow youtuber John
Krasinski and do like a good-news themed
episode where we reported the past five
good news stories of quarantine and it
was just like the thing about good news
is that it's always good but it's not
necessarily interesting so there's not
much to say when like somebody does a
nice thing it's very sad but it's like
it's just not nearly as interesting it's
like something salacious so Jackie and
I'd be like the first ten minutes were
just like reporting on these stories
like so nonsensically and then once we
realize like what we weren't even
speaking words it just turned out to be
so funny I really feel like you guys
will enjoy it it was one of my favorite
episodes
in a really long time yeah but also
because we got to record it together
which yeah I just missed that magic but
speaking of magic yesterday's episode of
the morning toasts just like got me
through the day yesterday it's been a
long time since I've just been like so
proud of a show that we've done where
it's just like I can point to multiple
moments that I think back and laugh
about and I just I don't know what was
in the water yesterday but it was such a
funny episode and it really is now that
you brought it up I think that we have
to address the major elephant in the
room which is the comma okay we need to
dress the comma I call Claudia yesterday
because I saw that she put a comma in
her Instagram bio and that was Naamah we
had discussed she also put a period
which we had discussed and decided you
were going to leave it open-ended so you
just went completely off book so when I
went to screenshot it to post it on the
morning shows Instagram it just looked a
little unfinished so I googled the
phrase just to see if there usually a
period like I just wanted to see what
the other intellects we're saying and on
brainy quote calm which is a very
reliable website it said law is reason
comma free from passion period so I
copied brainy quote and everyone was
making fun of my like grammatical vibe
and I'm sorry that I'm an intellect okay
two things are happening here one you
are a comma abuser and so when I first
saw the calm I was just said oh my god
she's just like dropping commas left and
right like what if I abuse commas I I
take that I'm not denying that I fully
like don't know proper grammar and I
just like put a comma whenever I feel
like I should breathe and the other
thing is that yes perhaps the exact
Aristotle quote is law is reason free
from passion but you were quoting
legally blonde clothing Aristotle and
that one goes the law is reason free
from passion I guess that's true should
I take it out yes and it should be the
luck cuz otherwise people don't know
that you think are actually quoting
Aristotle when they see that they don't
think of professor stromwell but if they
keep telling me that the creators of
Legally Blonde didn't use brainy quote
like there's no duh no they were taking
their own creative liberties even though
like the law is reason
oh I took out the comma yesterday I
guess I like fell into the peer pressure
but I'm leaving the period okay but can
you put the in front of law because
that's a quote that's on the blackboard
and I just and the law is reason free
from passion love it so if you want to
go to my Instagram take a look at my
Instagram bio and then click the link in
my bio and pre-order my comedy special
just grace tween now available for
pre-order on iTunes it will be available
on a few other platforms afterwards but
make sure to get your pre-order and to
support a burgeoning comedian thank you
so much love you have a great day plus
drought and today can your shoulders
I've been using tan Lux mom because I my
skin was turning green and Quarantine so
I've been doing like gradual
self-tanning every day and I think that
I'm getting tan I've been doing it as
well I've been on the 10th this is not
an ad Jack and I both I bought the tan
lux drops and then I hooked it up for me
and Jackie I got us both the full line
of products and I've been doing the face
for most of quarantine it's the only
thing keeping me looking like a morsel
of a human being but now that I got the
full products I did my legs last night I
finally shaved my legs Wow ya know I'm
really like dedicating some time to my
body and soul and I feel really good
about it
like I've been tanning just everything
and I feel like you can sort of tell you
can yes it's only day two yeah yesterday
when you asked me if you look tan like I
you did it but you actually do look tan
today yeah well I felt tan you know so
that counts 10 is definitely more of a
feeling than like a visual thing yeah
like I felt like I was just like walking
around like I had fresh spray tan on but
meanwhile oh I'm so dramatic like I put
the stuff on my legs I'm gonna get into
bed and they're like sprawled out I'm
like then don't touch me
yeah no totally but no it hasn't seen my
sheets honestly um when I got the tan
luxe box a lot of people are asking me
to do reviews and stuff and this is like
my review it's fabulous definitely got
it I'm up 7000 smell and it doesn't seen
your sheets not in that um I wore makeup
all day yesterday like I just didn't
take the makeup off like I worked all
day in my bed with a face of makeup on
just because I didn't want to let like
my morning of hard work go to waste
and I have a few fresh pimples you can't
really see it on the scene but I'm
pretty excited about it it's just
something different oh that
exciting I thought you were gonna be
upset and then I'll be like darn you
make up no it's like proof that like my
like I'm still human do you know what I
mean like all the orifices are working
like sometimes when you lay in bed for
days at a time you just feel like
nothing yeah like a robot yeah of course
Jackie and I are going to deliver The
Fast Five we are also doing dear
toasters because it is our weekly advice
segment today's Wednesday so if you ever
want to write in you can write into dear
toasters at gmail.com we will always
keep it anonymous and we cover anything
from quarantine quarrels to whatever
whatever you got for us we'll take what
you can get and then we also have a new
segment today which I am so [ __ ]
excited about yeah we'll share it when
we get there like it's gonna be treat
waiting for you after the Fast Five yeah
and it was an idea I just have to say
that happened so naturally on the
patreon episode that we were just
talking that's when we like said if
everyone to hear this like pretty much
irrelevant pay trottibus owed but it's
so important no it's so irrelevant like
your life will be completely the same
but you will just have like I think it's
a short one - it's like 32 minutes of
just like pure energy laughter joy like
I'm pretty sure and if you hear any
silence as ever it's because we're
[ __ ] wheezing cuz we're silent when
offers wheeze City yeah totally sure but
hey I think we should get right into it
I had like one more thing to say but it
has escaped my mind so without further
ado it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast oh oh no she's frozen again I feel
like she has something to say and I
don't know if she's gonna get a chance
to say it because she's frozen she's
frozen in a funny position - that's
something to say can you hear me now I
have something to say now we can hear
you say oh god now we can hear you you
were frozen I know I realize that I
couldn't hear you the whole time and it
must've been too late so don't yell at
me I have something to say please
actually I take that back I think you
have something to say
and I think you actually might want to
sing it wait
a few things that I like to sing so so I
want to wrap it or I want to sing it I'm
gonna wrap it he just took a DNA test
turns out he's a hundred percent Russian
even when he's fleeing countries he's
got heart problems that's a puppy in him
bling bling then he sauces that's a
doctor him he could have had a bad Tigs
noncommittal
helped you with your welfare just a
little you used to hold him down and now
you're holding him back and that's the
sound of his wolfy miss leading the pack
Wyatt is great till he gotta be great
don't text him tell it straight to his
face best friend sat him down in the
salon chair he needs to be groomed it's
been three months in the queue that's it
you know mommy's gotta work but I love
hi little man boy what Jackie was trying
to say but maybe you didn't get it
today's episode is brought to you by
embarked vet oh I'm out of breath give
me a minute you have you ever been in a
situation where you were walking your
dog and someone stops you with a how
cute what kind of dog is it and you
don't know you're not alone every year
millions of dogs are rescued from
shelters and that means there's a lot we
don't know about them you can finally
know your dog with an embarked breed and
health tests from breed traits to
genetic risk factors for health
conditions embark provides the resources
to help you and your vet best tailor
care to your dog's specific needs you
know a lot of the rescues and shelters
in New York are completely empty because
people got dogs in quarantine so we feel
like it's never been a better time to be
an embarked vet customer 100% over 50%
of dogs are either at risk or a carrier
of genetic diseases whether there are
purebred mix or whether they're pure bed
or Amex and embarking give you a leg up
when it comes to knowing their health
story it is the best drug DNA test kit
on the market I got one a while ago and
tbg just got one because he just rescued
the cutest dog and it was just so cool
like they send you like a little q-tip
you like put it in little Theo's little
mouse and then they give you a label
it's so easy and then they just text you
when the results are ready and it's just
so interesting cuz do you know he's an
above average dog here's a 3%
wealthiness
yeah that's wealthy as hell the embarked
dog DNA test kit is the most
comprehensive kit on the market market
looking at over 350 breeds types and
varieties and a hundred and seventy-five
genetic health conditions to help you
best care for your dog it is the only
company with stellar customer service
and vets and veterinary genetics
geneticists on staff to talk you through
your results it's super easy to get
started it's great if you're a dog mom
dad dog uncle or if you know someone
who's obsessed with their dog it's a
great gift too it's the best in class
dog DNA test kit it is number one rated
highest by customers and I think that
everyone really just needs to get
themselves in embark test and if you go
to embark am b AR k ve t dot-com you
could check it out use the promo code
toast to save fifteen percent off your
dog breed and health kit visit embark
vet EMBA RK v et dot-com and use the
promo code toast to say 15 percent off
today embark bet.com
promo code toast that's an exclusive
offer you can only get here so make sure
to check it out amazing ok first story
the big story of the week is slowly
coming to an end
Alex Cooper released her first solo
episode of call her daddy single father
called the funeral um where she explains
what the show's gonna be what you know
she's been up to
she talks a little bit about the drama
in the beginning and just sort of more
about her stance on it talks about new
formats for the show and then she does
Q&A where she talks more about Sophia
and soot man and kind of actually drags
them um which she hadn't done up until
this point but there were some harsh
words in in that but um the first
episode is hearing she's she's going it
alone yeah I feel like before this
episode I had faith that like maybe it
wasn't like the Great Divide like maybe
they didn't despise each other maybe
like they could in a year like make some
sort of reunion I don't know but after
the podcasts which I listened to bits of
I just didn't listen to the whole thing
but it's clear that she said some some
unkind things about Sophia so it's I
don't think there'll be any sort of
reunion anytime soon
no I don't think so at all I listen to
the whole thing there was some new
information but more so stuff is just
about like how their relationship has
been deteriorating for a while now it
wasn't like they both went up to Dave's
roof like best friends so excited blah
blah blah and then it just slipped from
there like there was a lot of stuff
brewing under the surface that
eventually came to a head so this was
gonna happen at some point somehow there
was a lot of just like resentment and
stuff going on and now that's why we're
at where we're at um she did a good job
I think her next episode she's gonna
have to Yvonne I imagine they're gonna
talk about this some more but I do think
it's it's time to move on ya know and
like you have to the show has to exist
outside of this drama because it's not
gonna last forever
and it is a new show now it's very very
hard to host a podcast by yourself like
I think I am the funniest most
charismatic person in the world and I
couldn't do it like it's so hard so I
look forward to seeing about like the
actual podcast is not the podcast that's
just recapping the drama which I'm
living for cuz the dramas you know
everything absorb yeah she said that
they're gonna do a new segment um where
they bring on in quarantine OB via phone
interview but they're gonna bring on
like members of the daddy gang to like
participate and like tell us their story
or whatever and just like sort of vibe
with Alex and you never know like where
things might go and who might be hurt
like one of those people could be her
next co-host but it seems like she's
really invested in the daddy gang
community honestly the way she was
talking about it I felt like I was
listening to a description of like camp
toast and the toasters like I completely
understand her love for the community
and just like what they do offline and I
completely if I can get it yeah wait
when you said she's bringing on members
of the daddy gang I'm like damn that
sounds terrible but now that I think
about it like the girls who like our
obsessive daddy gang and who would like
opt to go on probably have like the
craziest stories like from college like
but I could never go on I would
literally have nothing to say but now
that I think about it it actually sounds
like a great segment yeah no people have
like wild stories and they I'm sure
their listeners are so interesting just
like them so I think it'll be
interesting and that's a good way to
know mix it up because you can't always
do an hour alone yeah I mean at the end
of the day it really just may
Smith Inc like how grateful I am that
were sisters like obviously I love you
but I'm just a very like inherently
jealous person and if I had had like a
business with someone who I didn't
really know anything to other than
friendship like I don't know I can't
imagine I wouldn't just be looking out
for myself all the time and I would have
found myself in a situation like this
like that's just me but I can't do
anything to you cuz your answer yeah it
really is interesting so now I try and
think about like duo's who are just
friends who aren't family who aren't
even co-workers where it's just like a
like you know there's a clear line um
how can anyone even make it work like I
mean if you have a relatively like
unremarkable show I don't think it's
that hard but there and there aren't so
many duo's who become major stars in in
podcasting but in anything else like in
work so I think it really only becomes
like dicey it's very Josie and the
Pussycat Dolls you know like they were a
trio and then they weren't yeah that's
true I guess when you hit that level of
Fame so quickly like it's hard to make
sure everyone like feels good about
everything um but now that I think about
it in like podcasting room there's so
many duo's like that do trying better
know who I think is a great example is
like Becca Tilly and Tanya rod very
successful and but they just have like
so much love and respect for each other
I don't and also by the way they work
for a media company it's actually quite
similar because their show is
iHeartRadio but I heard radio a I think
is a little bit more buttoned up
contractual e then barstool so like I
think the barstool environment thrives
off these kind of moments in the media
and they almost even encourage it so it
I don't think it could ever happen for
like a becket Illiana Tanya rat
yeah it just wouldn't be so publicly but
there might be like private drama
yeah but they worked great together yeah
they do so it can be done I just I think
there were a lot of different factors
that made just as like a perfect storm
like Alex really goes into like the
history of Sophia and Superman's
relationship and like how from the
beginning like she found him to be very
controlling and then like once they were
in a relationship Alex felt like it was
her in suit man who were call her daddy
like Sophia was always just like saying
what Superman said so like Alex's
partners now Superman
and she does not know this man and that
was frustrating for her so I can see how
that's frustrating but also if I was
your friend and like I confided in you
about stuff about my boyfriend and then
you like even if we're fighting like you
put that on air like that would actually
really upset me
of course I didn't think about that
because I'm sure their roommates like
they know everything about each other so
this is like they have ammo on each
other beyond just what happened in the
deal yeah and I'm sure there's so much
more I'm sure there's stuff Alex didn't
say I'm sure there's stuff that maybe
Sophia could say but won't say I don't
know where they're even gonna draw the
line in terms of messiness but um last
night was really the first the podcast
like she really sort of just turned and
it but it also requires an explanation
you know this man was in your guys's
lives for a year did he just wake up one
day and say I think I'll own color daddy
today yeah yeah but that is no yeah I
would agree
no yeah like the wheels have been in
motion for a while well I'm just curious
to see where this goes
yeah me too but I'm glad the show's back
on track back on the air um and I wish
her the best of luck
truly women supporting women podcast
host you got this girl Fred you can call
us if you need any advice totally okay
next story a little legal news Hayley
and Justin Bieber are threatening to sue
a plastic surgeon over surgery claims a
Beverly Hills plastic surgeons blowing
up on tick-tock after posting a video
suggesting Haley Bieber's had some work
done on her face but now it's got him in
legal hot water with Halley and Justin
dr. Daniel Garrett's been hit with a
cease and desist letter by the couple's
lawyers who claim he's using Haley's
name image and likeness in his video
without permission to advertise his
practice and spread false uncorroborated
claims that mrs. Bieber has undergone
plastic surgery on top of that Barrett's
being accused of copyright infringement
for his use of lyrics from Justin song
sorry
in the caption damn they are going in
yeah they're like going in on this
random doctor and while I do think like
doctors he is tik-tok to like promote
their practice and then like take down
celebrities like this whole thing's
[ __ ] up but at the end of the day I
don't know if it's necessarily a league
oh there used to be a segment another
segment um like a series
one of those tabloid magazines like in
touch people where they had like
prominent Beverly Hills la doctors
taking pictures of celebrities and being
like this is what she got a nose lift
according to doctor miss Arden or
whatever yeah you got a nose left filler
there's the line for the facelift like
technically you'll [ __ ] know that but
I don't know if this is necessarily
illegal yeah well we'll find out I mean
it's interesting that they're even
spending their time on this but I
understand it's frustrating like just
putting you know the kibosh on it for
once and for all
yeah and I can't say that if I didn't
have the money and resources such as
some bieber and haley bieber have like i
wouldn't just be petty as [ __ ] yeah i
don't know if i would be seems like
there's better ways to spend your money
but maybe they're just trying i don't
know for some reason maybe this just
really bothers him maybe she really
hasn't had any surgery and like wants to
prove to the world who always says she
had surgery fascia surgery maybe they do
I just don't care like I think she's
beautiful and if she achieved that face
with the surgery like cool like that
doesn't change that for me what is he a
surgery shaming cool it give me the name
of the doctor yes please I will take a
referral code yeah for sure
this is like weird and random and I
don't I I mean I don't know the law and
I but I do know the laws reason for you
from passion but I don't know the
specific California log and I don't know
if this is considered a legal yeah but
this does feel like passion and so if
it's reason free from passion then I
don't think this will hold up in court
yeah that's like the formula yes so
spoiler alert that's the thing about the
law though it's so reason free from
passion yeah okay this next story is so
infuriating the V not the outcome the
video itself a lot of people have
probably seen it but a woman who was in
a park with her dog not on a leash who
calls um 900 and there's a black man
threatening her if you haven't seen the
video like I want you to watch it just
so you know what we're talking about but
it's so uncomfortable and it's very
disturbing
yeah but update Amy Cooper the white
woman in a recent viral video seen
calling the police on a black man who
asked her to leash her dog in a wooded
area of New York City Central Park has
been fired from her job franklin
templeton investments and asset
management firm announced its decision
to terminate Amy on Tuesday just one day
after footage spread across social media
that showed her berate Christian Cooper
an unrelated black man who was
bird-watching in the area and who told
her to put a leash on her dog because
her dog was not a leash and your dog's
needs a leash there's a big sign in the
park ya know there are certain areas
where I think you can take your dog off
a leash but I don't I hate seeing dogs
off their leash like it's just like this
it's anarchy you know if we were talking
we're outside like when they're inside
they get off leash like I just don't get
it so this woman was like so nasty in
the videos just really I don't know what
other word to use other than disturbing
like what like literally she's standing
ten feet away from the guy and she's on
the phone with the police saying this
black man is threatening my life like he
literally could have been further from
you it was just like it's very
disturbing and I am oh and another
update in the story what was also really
disturbing about the video is that she's
like manhandling her dog by the collar
around his neck like literally choking
him she's like oh why the dog isn't
crying and squirming and yelping she has
even realized she's [ __ ] choking her
dog while she's like trying to protect
the right for him to not be on a leash
and she's choking him just put my
legally choke she surrendered the dog to
a local shelter after much outrage whoa
yeah so I can't stress enough like how
anti pet cancel culture I am but every
now and then there is just a certain
genus it qua like a certain situation
that just requires it yeah like this
woman which is committing like a bevy of
disturbing crimes in one video and like
it's not even like she's a celebrity so
like this is the way she acts in her
regular life and it happened to go viral
like thank God because like maybe she'll
change her behavior like everything she
was doing in this video it's so [ __ ]
up Shuggie
this is the way she acts when she's
knowingly being filmed yes she thinks
she's in the right right and she's so
like grounded in her beliefs and like
she knows she's on camera yeah that's
her filtered down version you
ya know this woman is nothing of the
sort I have to say she's been China like
I hope that all this backlash will make
her realize like she's completely in the
wrong she needs to rethink who she is
and what she's doing she's so rethink
who the [ __ ] she is
she's been also like releasing
statements as she spoke to CNN and it's
strange because they're very well
written I don't think she has a
publicist I think she's like a like
maybe an like a educated person so I
just can't I don't understand how you
can just like work out a finance like
you can work your way up and just like
also be so dumb yes she said it was
unacceptable and you know words are just
words and I can't undo what I did but
but I sincerely and humbly apologize to
everyone especially to that man and his
family wench when she died okay so
wedgie yeah are you ready for our next
story it's just some exciting streaming
news in the queue because HBO max
launched today
HBO max launch today they have had a
truly fabulous rollout of advertisements
I was walking Thea yesterday and they
keep doing these ads where they're like
comparing types of content that they
have so they had an old movie I'm gonna
mess it up I don't know what it was it
was giving me Gone with the Wind vibes
and then Oscar the Grouch and they were
like this one has a toss a bass and this
has one oh you know what I saw that ad
too and I was confused because I thought
it said HBO Mac so you've got eight
Oscars in one Oscar I'm like you only
have eight movies that have Oscars no no
so I think it was like that one movie
they were showing whatever they're just
like doing great I'm excited I mean I've
said I was gonna subscribe I have a
brand new Apple TV that has truly
changed the course of my life and I'm
downloading that [ __ ] ASAP also a little
good news for Ben is that Harry Potter
has been added to the library the full
catalog of movies so that's how you
could like persuade him be like I got
this for us I will be sure to not tell
him that because he will make me watch
it it's good like there's worse things
he could watch I'm not really not for us
oh you know not that it's a news story
but JK Rowling did announce another book
it's like a whole new series oh wow good
for her
yeah I'm happy for her know that I am
okay well congrats to the HP IMAX family
um looking forward to more content all
the time yeah no I
I really needed this I'm very excited I
hope it doesn't flop like I don't think
it will can you get um like if you paid
for HBO do you get a subscription or
it's like totally different and separate
oh it's so confusing my newsletter was
trying to explain today like everyone's
on a different level and there's like
it's really confusing there's a website
that kind of breaks it down like if you
get if you pay for this you get it if
you don't like I don't like writing
because I was downloading all the new
apps from any Apple TV and I downloaded
HBO and I get to downloaded HBO now and
I was trying to log in with like my
cable and it wouldn't let me then you
had to go to HBO go like there's some in
HBO go HBO now HBO max and then like HBO
yeah there's a lot they need to
consolidate and I guess that's what HBO
Max is oh I don't know that I'm just
like sense they should they should be
what it is but it probably isn't okay
this next story is kind of strange um
but I just thought it was interesting
and you just want to hear your opinion
um
the Bolivian orchestra has been stranded
in a German castle for entire quarantine
so when quarantine started the Bolivia
orchestra group was inside the 600 year
old castle in Germany and now they've
been there for three months now they
arrived just before the country went
into lockdown and closed its borders the
group of musicians has been keeping busy
practicing their instruments as they
stroll the grounds of Rhines burg palace
outside Berlin which is believed by some
to be haunted by the ghosts of snitches
[Laughter]
pass/no the ghost of Frederick's are
great and is also surrounded by dozens
of packs of wolves
so this orcas show stranded in the
haunted castle and that just sounds like
so much fun it's so beautiful yeah I
mean it's bucolic for sure and you know
I don't know what's better be sure I did
in a haunted castle
like shacked up in your tiny apartment
am I supposed to feel bad for these
people what's the point in the story it
was just like interesting that they got
stranded in a castle and they're still
there a lot of people who got stranded
in the beginning like whether they were
on vacation
I remember that article about that
couple who like was on their honeymoon
they were like okay well just like right
out here and then it turned out to be
like weeks and they like we're the only
ones left and they had to get home and
they got home but this Orchestra has not
gotten home well I have questions on the
logistics of getting stranded like let's
say you're at a hotel or like renting a
home and you literally can't leave
yourself to paper night yeah well that's
ideal for the homeowner yeah it is so
but what if you can't what if you can't
afford it well then you need to leave
like with all of the lockdowns they gave
a little bit of warning even if it was
just like 12 hours
that you got a gtfo yeah and some people
just made the decision to stay where
they were
yeah like Kristin Cavallari and our
favorite girl Kelly Ripa oh of course of
course so I just feel like that would be
like a cool place to be with an
orchestra and a castle it's like so
Beauty and the Beast it tells all this
time where's the castle Belgium yeah I
mean the movies that are gonna come out
of quarantine like different stories who
relic moments like I'm looking forward
to the content for sure it's Berlin
sorry not paljah oh absolutely I went to
Berlin once not my favorite city Berlin
once and I did not feel safe I went to
New York once when I 1981 and I just did
not feel safe I married the wrong woman
and now I leave my breast but I love
that movie Ted actually you know what
I'm gonna watch that movie haven't seen
it in a while it's so [ __ ] good if
you guys don't know what the scene we're
talking about is when they go to the
aquarium and they like start mimicking
with the fish are thinking and it's just
so funny it's so funny there's so many
classic moments in Ted 1 & 2 was 0 to 3
or we're like we're still championing
that concept
we're championing it but like tattoo was
just a disappointment for me personally
oh I totally disagree don't ever tell
you I met Seth MacFarlane it took like
everything inside me not to tell him to
make Ted 3 yeah
yeah I know I know that you met him I
don't know if he knew that like he was
sitting across from a girl who was like
his actual number-one fan
I know it's probably best that he did in
but we'll always know
yeah we'll always have Ted we will
always have I love Ted and it's the type
of movie that you need to watch you need
a long amount of time in between
watching it because you want to like
forget the joke so you can be real apt
you know mm-hmm
it's not the best time it's the best
night they were pretty fast and there
were five of them so Before we jump into
your toasters which is our advice Eggman
we are going to introduce a brand new
segment that was birthed from an idea we
spoke about earlier this week about you
know the whole the whole industry of
mindless news specifically surrounding
one person her name is Kelly Ripa so I
think Jackie has a little jingle she'd
like to sing oh yes now it is time for
Kelly's mine this news that's not what
we agreed on okay
I don't remember that's to listen to the
patron episode because we came up with a
jingle for it's Kelly's mindless news if
you ever need a reminder it sounds like
Becky Gees shower like the fourth of
July Kelly's mindless users Kelly's
mindless news like the fourth of July
yeah it has nothing to do with shower
Kelly's mindless news like the fourth of
July your hair is not the song you light
me up inside like the fourth of July
Kelly's mindless snooze are you really
telling me you don't hear the
similarities Wow so sad you have no
musical talent oh my god this is like
painful yeah at least my lists news like
the fourth of but now you're singing it
like the song Jackie I'm telling you
like this was it's Kelly's mindless news
Kelly's mindless news like this
[Laughter]
Kathleen's - share the [ __ ] - okay
and today's second mind is too full and
I needed to be mindless alright well
here you go
in today's episode Kelly's mindless news
is from The Daily Mail thank you tell
email I don't know how I would survive
without knowing that Kelly Ripa revealed
she has been covering up a sty in her
eye for four weeks as she joked she
deserves Emmy for special effects makeup
okay has confessed she'd been suffering
with a stubborn sty in her eye during
quarantine the TV hosts revealed her
issue on Tuesday's episode of live with
Ryan and Kelly where she joked she
deserves an Emmy for makeup special
effects after covering up the infection
for four weeks while discussing their
Primetime Emmy nominations the 49 year
old said I also deserve a special Emmy
oh she's oh my god she's so obnoxious I
guess Emmy nominations came out and they
got a bunch and Kelly said that she
deserves what and for the Emmy for the
special effects like she's like I don't
know who got nominated maybe like Best
Director like all the people who work
hard and she's like saying she deserves
well I can't like honestly of all the
Kelly's mindless news that we can report
on like her having a this kind of crazy
um cuz just as like spies are crazy to
me um but I I feel like completely -
yeah and I don't want you to worry and I
don't want anyone at the you know
listening this listening to this at home
Toria because she explained she's been
using warm compresses and appointment on
the lump don't worry she's she's all
over it even though she says those
haven't been working I had a date that
you will find a regimen that works and
that when she does she will share it
with us and we'll be reading it in
People magazine on the cover also four
weeks is a long time to have a sty no
it's definitely unhappy um I actually
pets ties my whole life they're just so
annoying they're not necessarily painful
but more just like the biggest annoyance
they are painful they can be really
painful when I get them it's not like I
feel like a throbbing it's like I feel
like my eyelid is just like heavy yeah
that makes sense
oh my god my doorbell just rang let's go
get it okay well that was Kelly's
my people are probably like you're just
leaving someone at the door no it's
probably just might they drop off
packages and anything ring the doorbell
well thank you guys for tuning into
Kelly's mindless news and now for dear
toasters is there anything else do you
want to break up anything before we move
into our final segment tear toasters
know what I had wanted to say was that
it's crazy that the Vanderpump rules
reunion was not on last night and said
it was a Secrets Revealed episode so I
just got to read my book which I was
glad about but like since when do we
just skip a week for no reason it's it
was yesterday a holiday I didn't know
about maybe they just needed more time
to edit together than 19 Sue's maybe I
may be crazy though yeah well these are
unprecedented times Jackie yeah you're
right okay dear toasters dear Claudia
and Jackie I want to start by saying I
love you listening to your show every
day gets me through and it keeps me sane
thank you my family is a farm a few
hours outside of the city I live in and
I've been hiding out there until life
returns to normal see the only thing is
I feel like maybe I don't even want to
return to my life after this oh my god I
totally feel you I had good friends a
decent job a nice apartment social life
etc but all this downtime has really got
me thinking that I might be ready to
leave it all behind and start a new
adventure
I don't enjoy texting calling these
friends it's turned into kind of a chore
I'm scared I'd realized that I don't
actually like them I'm not even really
looking forward to going out or
returning to the activities I thought I
once enjoyed in fact I think that might
dread that when it happens is this
normal or the quarantine talking what
are we missing my friend slash social
life if I genuinely enjoyed it I can't
tell if all this downtime is just making
me overthink and go a little nuts or if
it's time for me to actually start a new
sincerely I confused and isolated a
toaster okay um this is definitely like
a big question for you and we can't
necessarily answer it but I will say
that like this pandemic quarantine is
really like a once-in-a-lifetime
hopefully sort of thing and if this
doesn't make you question your life
choices I don't know what will I do
think that you feeling this way like
that there is a lot of marriage to it I
think a lot of people are questioning a
lot of things about their lives because
you realize in quarantine the things
that are important and that we've been
just placing value on things that are
unimportant and if you and I feel like
even for me like this has really made me
realize like I live in the wrong city
for myself
and it now's the time to make those
changes and you can always blame it on
the queue you know I think a lot of
people are gonna be making major changes
after this so if you don't want to like
raise a lot of alarm you just like blame
it on the queue you know I definitely
think you should return back and just
see if it was the queue talking or if
you go back and you really just don't
enjoy the things that used to make you
happy I think that if you just were to
never come back like that might be a
mistake
but I think go back when everything
returns to normal and just see it's like
the way that you were feeling is more
than just the quarantine talking like
maybe this is how you actually feel and
I feel like a lot of people who like
fled their city apartments and like
their city life for like a friend or
their family's house like it really
opened your eyes I think a lot of people
who live in cities are having this kind
of breakdown yeah and also a lot of
people who live in cities are leaving
the city like not just for quarantine
like permanently or buying second homes
and it's gonna be like a big migration
out of cities I think and you can just
be a part of that and I don't think I
don't think that's strange at all I
think good for you for figuring out
where you want to be and where you don't
want to be I agree and good for you for
being in tune with those types of
emotions and like leaning into it yeah
okay that was good one next up
hi clapping Jack we're on a nickname
basis actually she wrote clods and
Jack's
well I'm desperately in need of your
toasty advice I'm 23 and live in New
York City but I mean quarantining with
my parents in the suburbs for about two
months shortly after coming home it was
brought to my attention that my
extremely hot neighbor was also home for
quarantine we went to high school
together he's a year older than me but
definitely knows who I am because it's a
small town he's tall dark and handsome
and so hot it's sickening naturally I
did a bit of sleuthing he appears to be
single in a recent grad of law school
does he know that law is reason free
from passion I mean he must know that if
you graduated the first thing you
learned first day my sister and I let
this opportunity pass us living a few
houses down from a total babe in high
school but my job extended work from
home through August so I'm planning to
spend the summer upstate I feel that
there is no time like the present to
shoot my shot I've added him on
Instagram been talking taking multiple
walks a day by his house run by the
filthiest run by in the filthiest
forever21 crop top i could find for my
childhood closet and we have waved in
passing driving by in the car but
nothing has come
my laying pursuits I've been at this for
a few weeks now and I don't know what to
do to get him to notice me and strike up
a conversation um what would you guys
suggest doing to let him know that I'm
admiring from afar I'm very single he's
very hot and I'm quite simply at a loss
help a very friendly neighbour PS
oliviers so much i watch daily and i
would be lost value guys thanks thank
you
okay so this is tough you've gotta get
his attention I'm following him I'm
Instagram was a good move like you could
you know find something on Instagram to
like send him and start a conversation
like that's kind of more introverted way
to get talking to him or like respond to
one of his stories be like oh yeah or
like send him something from like the
yard that you know the neighbor might
find interesting or you just like you go
up to him and you talk to him like you
have to find the right time maybe you
need to organize like a little backyard
be bq4 that's what I was gonna say like
a little block party um and this feels
like a hallmark movie and I can't think
of any me cutes that aren't like
hallmark II you know you could think of
it in this setting of Desperate
Housewives because this is so something
that would happen like you could go and
be a Susan or you could go and be an ET
to Mike delfino's house like show up
with like a pie and like your nipples
out you could do that that totally works
it works reading Gordon yeah Wow and be
like hey Mike like I need my clay my
sink unclogged yeah you could definitely
show up with a pie and with your nipples
out and I think that that would like
garner some success um but you could
also just say you need a plumber like
both both avenues work um or you have to
use have your parents I call his parents
and they can write oh my god no do not
do that I think the backyard Beebe kid
was the best option like you know it's a
New York okay okay yes yeah yeah you
should have a backyard bdq4 like the
young people on the block turns out it's
just you your sister and him and may the
best woman win
know will show up so like it looks like
there's more people on the block like it
wasn't just so intentional but actually
I think I'm too beautiful like maybe he
would want me and you know just wouldn't
want to distraction OBM yes so it you're
on your own I just think you've got a
and you know what like everything is
temporary what's the worst that can
happen you know just put your
out there try and find like a cute
situation to finagle you know maybe you
like our going house-to-house selling
cookies like for charity I don't know um
thank you girls do what you should do is
like shoot your shot in major way and if
it blows up in your face like don't keep
quarantining at your parents house yeah
then you have to come back to the city
change your name like get a new haircut
and like that's fine yeah we can help
you don't worry just backyard vbq I
think is the best option here yeah and
moral of the story is just is put
yourself out there he's not like as much
as I'm sure he would be you know so
happy to be with you he's also probably
just really bored and stuff and like
does he have siblings he might be born
in housing in the house warden like he
just would love someone to come up to
him and try and hang out yeah I agree
all right third and final do toasters I
love you all so much but to get right to
it I have a major question about social
media use while in a relationship my
boyfriend and I have been dating for
about four years and we just moved in
together I recently saw a girl comment
with the fire emojis on his last post so
of course I went to look at her profile
never heard of her before I saw that he
likes the majority of her posts and even
comments some fire emojis on her pics
I'm sure we all agree that fire emoji
means hot right can I ask him who she is
or what's up with that can he ever ask
her boyfriends about fire emoji comments
also I obviously hearted her fire emoji
comment and I'm tempted to just add her
to show that I see the virtual
interaction but hello I don't want to be
a weirdo and post fire emojis on
someone's post when they are in
relationship or am I the weirdo please
help my emojis are very strange I feel
like if he is commenting on someone's
public profile fire emojis like there's
not probably anything going on because
if there was they wouldn't be like
publicly but it's just weird like a been
left to fire moji I'm like one of like a
like a girl my age like a not a
celebrity like just a girls pic I would
be like excuse me yeah it would depend
on who the person is in relation to my
husband like if it's his girlfriend like
friend girl I mean that would be like a
weird comment but I would just be like
oh he's having a weird day um but like
if it was someone that I never heard
about I was just I think I would bring
it up like what you think she's hotter
like you want to burn it down like what
is going on right do you hate her so
much you want to burn the [ __ ]
lames of her life or do you think she's
hot because he could you know what you
can't just assume it's hot yeah yeah he
could be saying like burden this burden
of all or he could be saying like let's
have a campfire like there's so many
things no but like ultimately what he's
saying is like this is flames and I
think it like I would I would do if I
saw it if I saw a girl I'm trying to put
myself in your situation if I saw a girl
that I didn't know and Zach was and
we're together for years so like you
pretty much know everyone in his life um
and Zach was coming commenting fire
emojis yeah I would be [ __ ] disturbed
no I would like I would be mad and it's
just so funny I'm like I if I have like
an issue or like Ben does something that
like I don't agree with I never have to
think about whether or not I'm gonna
bring it up like they just storm into
the other room and like attack him maybe
I should start thinking before I speak
yeah like initially keeps himself closer
to the chest and then like yeah closer
to the vest and then be like you did
this any less firemen geez
well Ben totally does that like because
whenever we fight he was like a [ __ ]
roster of things he wants to talk to me
about and he's like what can you think
of an example I'm like no I don't right
oh my god that is the worst can we think
of an example no I'm I'm trying to
forget
no and that doesn't make my argument
less valid the fact that I didn't write
down in the moment like five months
about something that made me upset if
anything it makes me a normal human
being no it's like it bothered me so
much I tried to forget about it yeah or
it's just like I just I honestly
fighting with Ben is infuriating because
he's a very good fighter
oh damn that's how I feel like that's
like fighting with me I would not want
to be in a fight with me I would rather
die like literally run me over with a
car throw me into a flames emoji I would
literally rather be dead than ever have
like an actual argument with you like
over our lives we've of course have like
maybe like five or ten arguments like
they're some of the worst times in my
life like I never what if I with you
yeah what's good for all my like enemies
though is that I hate fighting so it's
not like I ain't like I don't go seeking
fights like it pains me to get to that
place but once I'm there hello she's
[ __ ] ruthless you guys ruthless very
strategic like she spits backs but like
you know they're they're strategically
placed
facts and now I just like I just really
have like the power of words you know I
guess you're just a good fighter thank
you thank you so much um by the way like
this isn't like a total deal-breaker
this flame situation but just bring it
up like bring it up I feel like he's
doing it so like out and open like not
trying to hide it it's probably not
anything salacious but it might be
something you want to talk to him about
stopping doing because it's like he's
out on social media being a public
representation of your relationship and
that might not be what you want people
to think and like maybe he doesn't know
like get the flames emoji like yeah
means like looking good but it's also
like oh I want to [ __ ] that's it um you
know sometimes like older people like us
like sometimes I'll find out one in the
Moche means and I'm like what it's it's
just a splash it's just an eggplant yeah
um so those where are your toasters
please submit to your toasters to us you
can email to your toasters at gmail.com
and as always anonymous thank you to
everyone who braved the unchartered
waters of Deer toasters it's good stuff
okay I think that's all she wrote I
really do yeah hiding her hand hurts and
so does mine so thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning to us the
Millennial morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so if you're watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that Spotify
iTunes stitcher Public Radio I have
radio cast box all the places whoever
you listen to podcast find us somewhere
neato something a five-star review about
a beautiful stunning it's where we are
we will see you guys tomorrow have a
fabulous day
bye